mike this dude had the bloods and cribs
after him what was that for
so
craziness
so
you have both of them after you no no
not both of them oh something
i was on one of the biggest shows on tv
for for a minute from like 2011 to 13.
scandal on abc who was like that was
kerry
yeah so it was me and kerry washington
you know what i mean but i was in a
horrible marriage man like
awful well come on
yeah like terrible but what happened you
know and i as i as i was getting bigger
my world was like
yeah my in my personal life and my my
everything in my world was controlled
that i didn't even realize it right and
who was in the middle of it she was so
she was you know she was sleeping with
you know i'm working 15 hours a day five
days a week i'm never home so she was
doing her thing
and but one particular dude she was
messing with was a blood or connected to
the blood
and i had knocked out
his cousin at a basketball court like
and i didn't know it was all connected
so
you know i got i you know she's
threatening my life she's you know we're
going through all these these changes
and scandal was like you need to get
away from this girl because she's
completely toxic
so i finally got the balls to be like
it's over you know what i mean get your
stuff get out
you know what hey mike he's right there
you fight you knew how to have boss you
really break up with a girl yeah like
she's hungry i don't think breaking up
with you no
you know she told me you know she you
know hate last longer than love i'll
spend the rest of my life destroying you
type so i was like okay
and uh so i finally kick her out the
house
and um so for like three weeks i'm like
it's quiet i'm like figuring out my life
like you know i got this 10 thousand
square foot house and i'm like i'm like
i'm i'm good and these bloods come to my
house
talking about they have no gate [ __ ]
yeah it looks kid they got through the
security gate how i don't have no idea
listen i got some [ __ ] with guns that
might get there you know no that's
the community so they say they want to
sit down at my table so you know and
they're like look they get me out
i'll let them in i was in that [ __ ]
funny enough i had two i was building a
studio at my house right and i had two
og with like og triple o g crips built
like building my build in my studio so
they were there they was like we good
let's sit down and talk let's set it
down and talk it out
they was like let's sit down and talk it
out cuz see what this is about cuz you
know what i'm saying what's this about
cass so i'm they everybody's sitting at
the table and they're like you owe us
this amount of money blah blah blah and
i'm like for what
what do i owe you money for so cut to
find out you know
she was pam using my money paying for a
dude's apartment paying for his car blah
blah blah they thought they could extort
me so i you know i was like i don't even
negotiate with terrorists
so y'all get out of my house
they leave the house
two days later
the police are at my house with a
restraining order saying i have 10
minutes to leave the property so she can
come and get all her things that and i'm
reading the order it says i threatened
to kill her threaten to kill my daughter
threaten to kill myself
of abuse next thing you know that's on
tmz
it's all over the thing i don't know
what the fake word says [ __ ] no no
so
no i had i i
i went crazy internally because i lost
my job i'm making 75 000 a week you know
what i mean like
you know i'm i'm i'm doing well for 24
weeks out of the year i'm like now i'm
i've lost my job on abc
disney disney ain't having that headline
saying i'm a i'm a i'm an abuser i'm a
kid like i didn't do that was a complete
lie
and i and everybody that's watching this
podcast right now everybody that knows
knows it
you know i mean i got i got railroaded
so i get a call from my account after
the headlines come out right headlines
come out columbus short abuses his wife
or threatens to kill blah blah blah
columbus shorts fire from scandal i mean
it was clickbait for like hot
hot three weeks my accountant calls me
he's like columbus you got to stop the
bleeding i said stop yes let's stop
bleeding what are we talking about he's
like your wife's you know she's taking
out
you know 300 and some thousand dollars
in the last two weeks i said what
i said well move the rest of the money
into the trust account yeah and they're
like
uh
what money you have four thousand
dollars left we just paid your taxes i
was like you got to be kidding me now i
got to go to court i can't afford an
attorney yeah so now i'm getting now i
got some public defender that can barely
remember my name
you
think you got something left in your tax
account you got nothing got nothing
nothing so now i'm like can't fight the
kids
so then i just plead it so that they're
like
you can go they're like exactly they
like uh you want to go to trial i don't
have money to go to no trial
i'm like you know so they're like you
can plead no contest and right now we'll
give you community service
so i pleaded no contest to some [ __ ] i
didn't even do
just because i didn't have money to
fight it the right way like you see
these hashtags right now free johnny
depp
uh-huh they free in johnny depp like you
know his wife accused him of johnny
dapper johnny debt